[Music] If you think that
earning money is the only goal,
you will end up doing things every day
that you don't like doing to earn money
and to live a life doing things you don't
like is such a ridiculous thing to do.
Nearly two hundred thousand people arrive
in Australia every year as migrants. [Music]
One-third of the small businesses are owned
by migrants. We wanted to find out what
makes them do what they do, what is their
motivation, what challenges do they face,
and after all these systemic odds and
hassles, is it really worth it? [Music]
I think it takes a certain kind of person
who's got a real tolerance for risk to be an
entrepreneur or just kind of really wants to have
that to own their own narrative. Everything around
you, look around you, every single thing that
you're wearing, every single piece of furniture
around you, every single building around
you, they've all been made by entrepreneurs.
Entrepreneurs are nothing but creators, right? So
we need creators in this world because only people
who create can make the world a better place.
An entrepreneur is a very different animal,
I would say, someone who thinks differently,
someone who sees the world differently.
As an entrepreneur, you will have a
very unique way of looking at things.
Melbourne has one of the most vibrant
multicultural communities in Australia,
and we were about to meet four entrepreneurs
to hear their stories. [Music] [Applause]
One day my boss told me, "Drop everything, stop
everything, come with me. You need to understand
why we do what we do." She brought me to
this beach cleanup, but the organizers
actually didn't want to call it a cleanup; it
was a beach audit. True enough, after an hour,
after we cleaned the beach, it was dirty again.
You know, that's when it hit me how big this
problem of packaging waste was. Ultimately,
I came here with a huge mission, which was to
figure out a solution to this packaging waste
problem. I think it was sometime in 2018 when,
like everybody else, I was in a nine-to-five,
still dancing but under my Guru, but always
wanting to understand how I can do something more
than this. I was trying to find more purpose in
life. For me to pursue entrepreneurship was always
a one-point decision. I see the possibilities when
it comes to entrepreneurship, and something that
really keeps me awake, you know, in a good way.
But only if it is that simple, there is no
doubt about entrepreneurs having to start
from zero. But being a migrant entrepreneur
often means you have to begin below zero.
A number of people I've met, including myself, we
have to start from scratch. Nobody knows nothing.
It's like you're born again. I mean, in terms of
challenges as a migrant founder, I think a very
direct one is that the migrant journey is designed
for employees. You know, the barriers to entry are
hard enough for entrepreneurs. It's a really hard,
um, and it's really hard to have success as an
entrepreneur, let alone if you're a migrant. You
know, you've already got language barriers. You're
potentially talking a little bit of xenophobia,
which still probably exists in Australia. But I
was raised with two sisters, you know, so I've
technically had three mothers, you know. So,
even at my home, if I want to drink or what else
I want to drink water in it's just being served
to me, you know, and here I am mopping a floor in
a foreign world, and particularly you feel people
are walking in with the suits and everything, you
know, because I was in a CBD district and near
Collins Street, so some of your community people
as well, very well dressed up, and they come
through and you feel I was just embarrassed to do
that kind of work, you know. I mean, I came over
here from England eight years ago. I was a lawyer
back in the UK and a captain in the British Army,
and I ended up picking fruits, doing door to door sales
because I had to start from the beginning...almost.
And so, for entrepreneurs, I think that's
why a lot of migrants come into the country,
get drawn into entrepreneurship because
you can go and build something yourself
and you can kind of own your own narrative,
whereas if you want to try drop into the job
landscape, you kind of got to reset. I think
having the willingness to just talk and open
in front of us, that would be the first thing.
So again, in our business, we are not selling
a product. You go and just do a transaction, ours
is a relationship business. Before we do business,
people need to know us, people need to like
us, and then people need to trust us before any
business happens. Just having that opportunity for
people to open up is not that straightforward. One
of the challenges as a business owner was that
acceptance. I think I found that journey a bit
challenging because just like anybody else, you
always want to be accepted, you've got to get the
trust of the people, so that took a while because
it's not just the clients that we're talking
about; it's also the community. So re-establishing
myself back in that landscape was challenging.
It's like sometimes we feel that we get
more criticized or analyzed by our own race.
Social challenges may be a subjective problem, but
financial support is very much an objective issue.
Disparities are still persistent; the
overall system needs many changes to
make it supportive for entrepreneurs. For
example, before 2021, the rules for visas
for entrepreneurs were so impractical that my
immigration agent told me that I was naive and
ridiculous for even thinking about a startup,
actually said, "Don't waste your time because
the whole system wouldn't benefit it." So, I'm
really close to a founder at the minute; she
is a first-generation migrant from the
Philippines, and her family moved here,
I think, 30, 40 years ago, and, you know,
she was born here but is really facing that
challenges both as a female and as a migrant and a
person of color in terms of starting her business.
So, she's currently fundraising, and finding all
that kind of unconscious bias is really impacting
her journey as an entrepreneur. I think for
her, it's, you know, we, with so much work
around that diversity space in terms of gender,
which is amazing, it needs to change the dial,
um, but she thinks that for her personally, it's
the bigger challenge is not being a woman; it's
her background in terms of where she's from. A big
challenge for us right now is financial support;
it's been a struggle trying to
get funding, even though there
are those systems that technically
exist. Yeah, yeah, does that work?
It's a good question, that does it work, because
it works, which means does funding happen, yes,
funding happens, but it's who does the funding
go to, right, and where does the, where do
people actually get the information or where
do they get the support? This year at funding,
in terms of investment into female-founded
businesses, was two percent of overall funding.
Now, in Startup Victoria, our membership is
42 percent female, and we're generally a very
early stage organization because that's
when founders need the most community,
so how does 42 percent translate to
two percent of the funding, there's
obviously somewhere where there's a huge
disparity happening. It is a brave thing to
start a business, but just because you're good
at something does not mean you will be good at
running the business. One of the things I think
most founders don't do is really understand why
they're building a business. If you understand
the why behind your building a business,
it becomes really apparent to you what you
want to do and what you want out of it. I'm
quite regularly brilliant people with awesome
ideas, great innovators, but they don't have
the commercial background in terms of how to do
business, those areas, especially, we see a lot of
people who struggle to commercialize their
business and actually make it successful beyond
the idea stage. In order to maintain the right
balance between goals, risks, and opportunities,
having a realistic mindset is necessary. I think
there are two sides to the coin when it comes to
migrants. They've actually gone ahead and proven
that they're resilient, they're adaptable. So
these are all qualities of a great entrepreneur
anyway, right? So, they've already got these
qualities, they've proven these qualities
already. We tend to overestimate the negative
impact of what could be, and we totally forget
or maybe underestimate what good that can do.
And so, when we tell this story that if I take the
plunge, if I do something on my own, I have more
negative insights into me than the positive
ones, and that sort of makes me do the wrong
thing because I'm not taking a balanced view.
This is one thing that I kept telling myself,
and this is one thing a wise man told me, and that
wise man is actually my husband. He said to me,
"There is an audience for Madonna,
there is an audience for Beyoncé,
there is an audience for Taylor Swift, there
will be an audience for Chandralaya." And that's
something that really stuck to me because not
everybody gets attracted to what you're offering.
While the right mindset is essential,
personal drive often acts as fuel
because although discipline can keep you going,
only emotions give you that kickstart. [Music]
It's almost like you've got a chip on your
shoulder because in two ways, one is you
want to prove to the new, the host country, and
you want to prove that you can do something. The
second part is you left your parent country.
People have different expectations, maybe you
have told them why you're leaving, and maybe what
you're doing here is not what you told them why
you're leaving. So you also have a point to prove
to them because when I was in uni, I used to walk
two and a half kilometers to buy my groceries
and walk back with all the groceries because
that way I can save money on a ticket
because I can use that money towards
buying groceries because there were times I
had no money to eat food. And one of my biggest
influences was my mother. I was my mother, still
is my mother, and in 2018 when I decided to take
the plunge, I got this very bad news that my mum
was diagnosed with breast cancer, and that really
pushed me back. So I started to embark on this
journey of starting the school, and I named it
after her. Little did I know that I was going to
lose my mother that very same year, so that was
one of the worst emotional journeys I have felt
in my life because this was a tribute to her,
and I wanted her to see it while she was alive,
and sadly she couldn't. But I know every day she's
up there looking and really loving this journey
that I've created for myself and for others,
and it's been such a gratifying experience because
if not for her, this wouldn't have happened.
I'm completely gratified. I think it's one of
the best things I've done for me, for my family,
and I feel I'm doing this, it's a purpose,
it's a very strong purpose that I've got.
Sorry, it's just...no, it's okay.
[Music]
While there are strong reasons
for their entrepreneurial journey,
not everyone is inclined to become a unicorn
story. The rise in economic inequality,
monopolies, and consolidation is also the story of
multinationals and unicorns. Entrepreneurship is
fundamental to a truly democratic society;
the unicorn narrative needs to change.
Yeah, I think the unicorn
narrative is really damaging.
You know, we meet a lot of founders that
have or entrepreneurs that have an idea,
and they start to come into the ecosystem, and
they straight away think there's either failure
or becoming a unicorn, and they're the only two
options. Being a unicorn, I think, has become a
fashion now. There's a lot of things that go into
these aspects, and so being tied to that dream of
a unicorn or a decagon, I think, makes it very
difficult for people to really see what success
means. So defining your success very at the very
start is important and then sort of thinking about
what is making it big for you really look like.
I think there's a necessity for more education in
what it means to define success for you and how to
have a good strong business without trying to go
reach too high and falling over. Like there are
lots of unicorns out there that have still yet
to show how to make a profit even in years into
it, and as Shimroth is saying, they burn so much,
supposedly, to create value, but if the value
that they create is kind of questionable,
something that's important to us is growing
sustainably, and obviously, we want to make money,
and we want to be successful, but at the same
time, we want our sustainable impact to be tied
to our bottom line, so that's something that's
important as we scale. There are startups and
small businesses that are not just about making a
profit; their definition of success is different.
It is equitable; it is inclusive, collaborating
with art organizations to create meaningful
conversations about social economic issues
through art, giving out really strong messaging.
That is success to me. And at the end of the
day, success to me is, am I fulfilled? Is my
purpose here fulfilled? So everything I do is
with people I love, people I care for, and,
you know, so to me, all of that needs
significant hard work, you know. So, but
while that is success, but it's a continuous
journey, you know, and I'm always, I always
say people need to have something that they are
really chasing, and for me, my big thing that
I'm chasing is always to be better than I was
yesterday, and for that, I need to work today.
It's not always you have to be a unicorn; you
can be a Zebra company if you want to. It's a
small business, sustainable business because end
of the day, I think when you look at the failure,
and fear of it, define what is failure
for you, define what is success for you.
If your business is contributing something in
society, if it is making people's life better,
you're a success. If you're contributing to
someone else's dream to make them happen,
that's a success. If you're contributing towards
sustainability, doing something for a larger
ecosystem, it's a success. I think personally
I've grown massively in a mental capacity.
I look at life so differently now; it's not a
nine-to-five anymore; it's a 24/7. Of how to, and
24/7 in a very happy way, you know. I'm not
cornering myself and saying, "Oh my God, I don't
know what I'm doing, no, oh my God, what is the
next thing we could do to empower these people,
how can I inject more cultural diversity here?"
All the setbacks, the failures, the emotional
dramas, all of that has really fine-tuned
me as a person, as an artist, as a teacher,
as an entrepreneur. The conversations, the
relationships, I would any day cherish all
of that. When we asked a lot of entrepreneurs the
same question, like you have gone through so many
hassles, so many low moments, high moments,
what do you think, whether it was worth it?
A very interesting question because from my
experience, like, throughout every milestone
on this journey, whether Zerotag will
play out in terms, you know, financially,
you know, that's something we'd have to see. I
do know that I've made my life so much harder
by trying to do something new. If we can do that
right, I'm just like then definitely be super
worth it. Yes, I mean, definitely, I feel this
journey, irrespective of what the outcome is,
I've learned a lot. When you're going through
something, you feel all the pain in the world.
I know the price I have paid for it, without that,
I wouldn't have what I have. But when I look back,
it is worth it. Oh, 100 percent. Absolutely.
One day, my boss told me, "Drop, okay,
stop everything, stop everything."
Then I was like, "What's up?" Then she was like,
"Okay, come with me, you need to understand
why we do what we do." She brought me to this
beach cleanup, but the organizers actually
didn't want to call it the cleanup; it was a beach
audit. There was a huge study being conducted, the
survey, the Marine letter, and an hour after we
cleaned the beach, it was dirty again. You could
see the plastic rolling with the waves, and you
know what was crazy? People were fishing there.
You know the idea of just, you know, how you fish,
just putting a string and then suddenly getting
a fish, it's just kind of like magic. But now,
what if the environment was filled with plastic?
Like, how could we even get food? That's when
it hit me how big this problem of packaging
waste was. Ultimately, like, I
came here with a huge mission,
which was to figure out a solution
to this packaging waste problem.
I'm Joseph, I'm the co-founder of ZeroTag.
My name is Shimroth John Thomas, and I am the
co-founder of ZeroTag. We are in the business
of designing technology for sustainability,
and we are trying to make refill shopping
mainstream. You know, my background's more
in like engineering and design. When I was
in high school, I was a painter, so yeah,
that is a question which is always changing.
I've had a very multi-disciplinary background,
so worked as an architect for a while, then
mainly worked as a photographer as well, a
photographer and a filmmaker, moved on to design,
and everything in the design field as well, from
branding to UI user interaction design,
things of that. After doing my masters,
it's been more of looking at new biomaterials,
and now, yeah, ZeroTag is the culmination of
all of those sort of learnings. Weirdly, I
didn't want to study art because I felt that
I wanted to see more of the world. If I went
into art, I would have learned more about how
to create stuff, but then I wanted to see the
world more and maybe even change the world.
When I was studying architecture and
working as an architect as well, I
found that a lot of the existing construction
materials in the market were highly unsustainable.
Muni, I started creating this affinity with
the homewares industry in the Philippines.
Part of that was, you know, I got matched
with a homewares company somewhere on a
different island of the Philippines that
focused on sustainable materials. That's
actually where my journey into sustainability
started. Okay, hello, hello, and welcome to...
There's just something about sharing a coast and
realizing how connected everyone is. So even,
for example, like at that beach audit, beach
cleanup, you know, some of the packaging we
found there had foreign languages on it, and
maybe wonder, like, how far did this plastic
drift? And then realizing how everyone is
connected by water. Just think of packaging.
Packaging was such a complicated thing where it's
functional until you're finished with the food.
So there's that, just like realizing this is a
huge problem, and I'm in this unique position to
do something about it. Having that background in
materials, that background in industrial design,
and even the whole art thing, like, maybe I can
do something about it. So I needed to learn more
about technology. So technology was one of my
weaknesses. I think, like, something I knew
nothing about, and the Philippines was not ready
to teach me. So that's why I came to Melbourne.
I took my masters of design innovation
technology at RMIT. I had this class,
and this is where I met Shimroth. All about
sustainability by design, and then we're looking
at biopolymers and all that. Basically, we came
up with this project that involved this refillable
packaging for wine. And then I started going
to places outside of the classroom, and that's
also started our entrepreneurial journey.
We wanted to try to tackle packaging waste,
and looking at the Australian context, we found
that a huge waste generator in Victoria was
actually the wine industry. We initially wanted
to go down that path of creating a new material,
but we realized that's going to be really
expensive. That's when we realized, you know,
maybe we can focus on the reuse angle and try to
use that label system that we thought of to scale
it across the food manufacturing sector and create
a software which can help tackle this issue.
Started with wine, where we started, where
we created the reusable bioplastic packaging
made from wine waste, and that's where we actually
learned about the importance of labels and digital
labels. We realized that that concept could be
carried forward into other food products. We tried
different ways to validate, you know. I do things
like have a house party or even like my birthday
and then have people over, and then little do they
know that, you know, they might have, let's say,
wine that was actually from a refillable wine
place and seeing how that would help people react.
For example, when it came to, let's say, you
know, one day I brought this huge bottle of beer,
at the end of the night, nobody touched
it. I was like, "Huh, okay, interesting."
And then so I asked, like, the people who were
still around, "Hey guys, like, you have a huge
bottle of Moon Dog beer here." And they're like,
"Oh, Moon Dog beer? I love Moon Dog beer!" Yeah,
there's like a whole bottle in the ice bucket.
And then they're like, "Oh, that thing,
like, to be honest, it looks to sus..." That's when
I realized how branding, which is usually a huge
function of these artworks, was also important in
driving consumer confidence, something that was
missing in the shopping experience was the actual
artwork as well as the stories of the wine and why
people would buy, spend thirty dollars on a bottle
which has no name or no label. So we wanted, with
our solution in ZeroTag, we could communicate that
information in a really visual manner. With milk,
it was more about expiry dates. So really, after
speaking to a lot of people, in customer, like,
millennials and millennial parents, we realized
that a big common problem that they all faced
was they would forget their milk, and it would
go spoiled. And something that we thought could
really help them was sending them notifications
and reminders to help them avoid this problem.
They're like, "Oh yeah, these are the ones
that have the most problems." It's like,
"Okay, so you know, we just wanted to solve a
problem." So yeah, like store owners that have
bulk food stores, cafe owners that are promoting
sustainable products, and other refill sort of
dispensaries, they've been the businesses
we've been talking to. Hey, hello, hello.
Wow, I'm Luke Phillips. We're
here at Into Coffee, Into Carry.
We're Zero Waste Cafe, and
recycling design studio,
and we've recently got ZeroTag onboarded Into
Coffee, which we're really excited about. Being
zero waste, we have takeaway milk, takeaway coffee
beans, obviously, takeaway coffee. They're having
a better, more transparent, and reliable system
around that. It's really exciting.
ZeroTag is providing, of course...
Trying to reduce friction points and make reusable
campaigning a more enjoyable experience. And the
big barrier for that is challenging convenience
culture, and they're doing a really amazing job at
really reducing those friction points and making
it a really pleasurable experience, start to end.
We opened up partly because we recognized
that there's an amazing community around
the local area that are working to solve these
sustainability problems. And we wanted to build
a hub to bring those people together, but also
use that pub as a bit of a laboratory to trial.
These plastics like straws, plates, cutlery,
and cotton bud sticks will be banned from
retail in Victoria from February 1st. Single-use
plastics make up about a third of our waste,
but most kinds of disposable drink cups and lids
are exempt. Disposable cups and lids have plastic
elements to make them waterproof, that's why
more than one billion still end up in landfill
nationally each year. So let's say, look, this
is a paper cup. As you can see, it actually has a
plastic lining on it. Cool. How do you think that
paper was supposed to be holding liquids anyway?
And then you think of your coffee cup moisture.
It's hot and also has liquids. That's like the
perfect recipe to start by degradation. How do you
think it was it would work to begin with? Like,
I think that we're actually so far from
creating that ideal sustainable packaging
that will solve all the problems. And for us,
like, reuse is the one that makes the most
sense. And from a sustainability perspective,
my background is materials engineering, and
something I'm quite frustrated about is how, you
know, even in engineering, how sustainability
is talked about, you know? I had to learn that
sustainability is not a material property; it's
contextual. It's about systems. Let's say, "Oh, we
have compostable plastic, right?" And then there
was a way that they defined compostable. And then,
like, "Oh, okay, checkmark." And then, so if it,
like, check this box, that must be sustainable.
And then turns out that, well, the system for
it to compost was actually highly unlikely to ever
happen in reality. It still produced microplastics
that still harm the environment. But, you know,
if you're, like, in marketing, right? And then
you're, "This is what the engineers are saying."
They'll say, "Okay, then I'll just promote this
as a green material." And now, now you have so
much pessimism of greenwashing. So we're hoping
to simplify that by saying, you know, how about
you just reuse, and we'll take care of the rest.
Whether ZeroTag will play out financially, you
know, that's something we'd have to see. Right
now, I've designed it so that it will, and also
designed it so that its sustainable impact will
scale as well. If we can do that right, I'm just
like, then definitely be super worth it. Over the
last few decades, single-use plastics have become
the norm, and it's just more convenient. So,
and that's just made life easier
for everyone. But at the same time,
if you want to change those habits, you need to
create a new system which can make life easier
for everyone. And to do that, you need to be
able to, as a designer, look at things from
different perspectives. It's not just about
creating a product; it's about creating,
understanding what each stakeholder sort of wants.
I understand why actually this problem is so hard.
You know, what I don't agree with is going
complete activist mode and saying, well, you know,
this problem of waste is because people don't care
enough. Seeing the other side of things as well,
you can have people that care, but just nobody has
a solution, and sometimes someone has to come up
with a good enough solution, and that's where
I feel like my whole responsibility is because
I was like I mentioned, like my background
is so unique, and I feel like this is that
unique perspective I can give to the world.
There's just something about creating also
that can just shut people up about problems
and just say, look, this is possible.
One of the biggest risks people take is
when they get on a plane, leave the country,
and the comfort and the family behind to start
everything new in a new world, in a new city,
new country, where probably they don't even
know anyone. That is the biggest risk one takes
in their life. But as they come in, as they start
settling down, they start forgetting their dream.
When I landed here in 2006, you know, that was
a dream. That was a dream for me. My family,
no one in my mom or dad's sides of the
family has ever gone out of the city. I
was the first person in the whole family to
ever get on a plane and leave the country.
My name is Chirag Soni. I'm the
founder and director of Soni Wealth
I'm from the western part
of India, a city called Ahmedabad.
So growing up as a child, I was very shy, and I
was very much in my own cocoon. One thing was very
important: I got to play cricket after school
every day. That was my big thing. On my 11th
birthday, my parents gifted me my most expensive
toy at that point in time, which was 400 rupees,
roughly if I put it in dollar value, that's $8.
I was always watching Grand Prix and Formula 1
sports on TV and everything, so cars were
always my thing. So from that point on,
I always thought that one day I want to own a
Ferrari. That was sort of my dream. My toy car
was a Ferrari that my parents gifted. I'm 37 now,
and I still have that toy car with me.
My dad had a very small business, a small shop,
2 by 2, a 4-square-meter space. That's where he
worked all his life. I started counting cash at
the age of seven. He started letting me go to
the banks from the age of eight. You know,
so I was always involved in doing things,
and I always wanted to do that. He said, "Just
focus on your studies for now." You know,
and when the time is right, you'll do that. But
my entrepreneurial journey really started when I
turned 16, and I was really keen to do something.
And that's when I started purchasing mobile phones
because it's pretty new. My dad gifted me one for
my birthday, and that's when I was like, "Okay,
it's something really great tool, and it's the
future." So I started buying some mobile phones
and started selling them. When I turned 18, I
got my first job, so I started working in a call
center. I used to work for BSNL, which is a local
telco here in Australia. So I worked in their call
center, and then I moved up to work for Vodafone.
And then two years I worked with Telstra.
So I migrated here in 2006 as an international
student. So when I was an international student,
I was doing telemarketing. And as soon as I
got out of uni, within the first three months,
I purchased my first property. My job was to call
people and ask them what they do for a living,
how much is their income, how many properties they
own. And every time I used to hear they have two
properties or three properties and they've been
here for 10 years, my ears used to go up. "Wow,
how can you do that?" Because where I come
from, people don't even own one property,
really. It's a big deal. And these
people were doing it. So it gave me
something which I call a possibility that it's
possible. So I really wanted to pursue that,
and I was very lucky enough to
surround myself with the right people.
But your dad is so much into business,
so much into inventing stuff,
so there has to be those genes somewhere
in you, right? That's all just surfacing.
No, I'm only the hardworking part. We got
married officially a month ago, but we've
been together for 9 years. We work together. We've
been working together for the past almost 5 years.
The key difference for our business is it's
completely built around relationships. For us,
our journey really starts with our clients.
Before we do business, people need to know us,
people need to like us, and then people need
to trust us before any business happens. So it
is a much, much longer journey before we end up
becoming business partners or clients.
A lot of people I meet day to day, and they
have a lot of dreams to talk about. And the
key difference is when I ask them, are you
really interested in achieving this dream and
are you committed to it? And most people are
often interested; they're not committed. They
start getting too comfortable with the job
they have, with the income they're earning,
the house they're living in. I have clients
that say, "Oh, I would love to drive a Merc."
But then somehow they get satisfied with Toyota.
Nothing wrong with Toyota, but that was the dream,
to drive a Merc. And along the way, they
just got kind of lost in that comfort zone,
and they gave up. You know, if you ask me when I
was 16, do I know where I will be when I turn 38,
I had no P.L. You know, all I knew was that
I want better things in life. I want to enjoy
some of the finest experiences, and, like, I
never knew, never worried too much about the
how. It's always the why, like I say, right? So
because of that, I enjoy each phase of my life.
That was 2006 when I really got an idea or from a
friend who told me that, you know what, I can come
here for further education. And that's when it
really struck, okay, how is it possible? I can't
really afford all this. And they said you can
work 20 hours here, and when you work 20 hours,
you can pay for your lifestyle. So all you need
to organize is some money to pay for your tuition
fees. And over the next 5 months, every single
day, me and my parents, we tried everything,
you know, possible for me to get a visa. We had
to go and ask people for help, and my dad was
willing to do that. My dad is someone who has
never really asked anyone for help, but he went
to some of his clients, his friends, and said,
"Look, my son wants to go overseas for study. He
needs a sponsor. Can you please help and sponsor
him for this?" So that was the first time I saw
my dad really getting out of his comfort zone. The
moment I landed here, I knew that, okay, what is
my main purpose? I came here, and one of the key
things was, I've seen my dad, the way he worked,
and I wanted to ensure that I can help him to
retire in the next 5 years. That was my key goal.
I was coming from a corporate career,
so I was quite successful in what I was
doing before I landed in this city. But
it wasn't the same. I thought I have all
those badges with me, so I was very happily
showing my resumes with all my experience and
everything, and I was like, I'll get a job very
easy. It wasn't that easy. The first job that
I landed was working in a 7-Eleven, and I had
to do 10 shifts on trial before they offered me
a role for $10 an hour. I used to cry because I
had to mop the floor. I've never lifted a mop in
my life. I was raised with two sisters, you know,
so I technically had three mothers, you know. So
even at my home, if I want to drink water, I want
to drink water, and it's a thing served to me, you
know. And here I am, mopping a floor in a foreign
world. And particularly when you see some of your
community people as well very well dressed up
when they come through, and you feel, I was just
embarrassed to do that kind of work, you know.
Then why did you stop?
Because I needed the money, you know. I needed
to work to earn money to buy food for myself. And
I said I need to keep pushing harder because
why am I here? What's my goal? And that's to
retire my dad and pay for my tuition fees and
punch forward. He's good at getting out of his
comfort zone. I feel, in general, I'm someone
that really likes to stay in the comfort zone,
but with him, I guess he's come very far. So he's
evolved over all these years by stepping out of
his comfort zone. As I kept progressing through
all of those things, despite how I was feeling,
that gave me more opportunities, you know. And
so that's why I always say, when you are in
your comfort zone, it's easy to hold on to what
you know. It's easy to give up on your dreams,
basically, you know. But if you really
know that this is what you want to do,
you have to commit yourself to
get out of the comfort zone.
One of the key things I did when I established
Soni Wealth was to create a platform where I can
bring like-minded people who can taste what I have
tasted because it's possible. And that will also
enable us to go and reach a lot of people who
need help doing that, which I thought when I'm
doing a job, you're kind of limited to a task or a
job that's assigned to you. It's often considered
something very fancy nowadays when people talk
about entrepreneurship, you know. But the reality
is being an entrepreneur is not an easy journey.
To me, entrepreneurship is not an overnight thing.
It is a lifelong thing, and you have to give in
a lot before you can build [Music] something.
He reads, he watches inspirational
clips, and also cooking shows,
street food cooking shows. I find it funny
that, you know, many boys, they would play
video games or whatever to relax themselves in
the spare time, and all he watches cooking shows.
I always believe it's just not about hustling
24/7; you also need to learn to switch off,
you know. If you can't switch off, if you
can't disengage yourself from everything
that goes into your day, it becomes very hard
to keep performing at your level best. Say if
I'm doing some housework at home, I would hear
the background of people cooking in the work
and explaining what's to put in ingredients
and all. He's watching that as his therapy,
so that's something he does as well. That's
because being an entrepreneur, you have to
give your 100% or try your best to give your 100%
every single day. And for you to do that, you have
to learn. For me, my downtime is really enjoying a
nice glass of whiskey, watching Bollywood movies,
watching cricket, cooking, you know. So I
find time to do all of this throughout my day.
I showed a glimpse to Deepak,
and he doesn't remember.
So the topmost challenge for me in our business
is having the right people because a business is
not built by the business owner; it is built by
the team that they have. So finding the right key
people to go with you on the journey is one of
the biggest challenges. It was a long journey,
so while I have a great team, but it's built over
the last 10 years. One of the common qualities
that my team has is that genuine passion to help,
and they're willing to go out of their way to make
sure that things work. Practice you to consciously
make an effort to do this. If there's no dream,
what's the purpose, you know? What's the purpose
of life if you don't have a dream, you know? And
if you're not working towards something, what are
you working towards? If you have a car, you have
a nice, fancy car, you know how to drive, yes,
you can get in the car, you can start your car,
you can start driving. But if you don't know where
you're going to, you will get somewhere, but that
might not be the place where you want to get. But
if you have a dream, if you know your destination,
this is where I want to get to, even though you
face a few hurdles, like I faced this morning,
I was trying to get in here, and three of
Ubers ditched me halfway through the journey,
and then I had to pay a surge amount to get here.
But I know I need to get here. And that's the same
thing when you start visualizing your dreams,
when you start working towards it, you know,
because you're working towards something anyways,
you might as well work towards something that you
want to really get to. Look, success to
me is ongoing, you know? It's a journey;
it's not a destination. The life I live right now,
to me, is a dream, you know? But a dream that I
envisioned for where I live is where I envisioned
for 12 years ago. I want to live the person that
I am living with, my partner, my wife, is the
person that I always wished to be by my side.
The team that I have built, that I work every
single day with, is a team that I envisioned for,
you know, my dream team. Everything I do is with
people I love, people I care for. And, you know,
so to me, all of that needs significant hard
work, you know. So, but while that is success,
but it's a continuous journey. And I'm always,
I always say people need to have something
that they are really chasing. And for me,
my big thing that I'm chasing is always
to be better tomorrow than I was yesterday.
And for that, I need to work today. [Music]
[Music]
My name is Deepa Mani.
I'm the founder and the artistic director of Chandralaya
an Indian classical and modern contemporary school in Melbourne.
The way I look at the business is it's an
institution to impart this very empowering
art form in the minds of both the young and
the experienced.
So, if you were to learn a language, one needs
to understand the ABCs, the alphabet, in order
to be able to string a word and then a sentence,
and to be able to speak fluently.
That is very much how we look at dance; we
look at birth not in the sense of understanding
the nuances, the fundamental structure of
the art.
So, Chandralaya focuses a lot on instilling
those fundamentals in every student.
And, like everybody else, I was in a nine-to-five,
if not more than nine-to-five gigs in it still
dancing, but under my Guru.
But always wanting to understand how I can
do something more than this.
The question in my mind started to get more
and more strong because I was trying to find
more purpose in life.
And one of my biggest influences was my mother.
She still is my mother.
In 2018, when I decided to take the plunge,
I got this very bad news that my mum was diagnosed
with breast cancer.
That really pushed me back, and in a sense,
the question of a bigger purpose in life started
to occur a lot more frequently in my head.
So, I started to embark on this journey of
starting the school, and I named it after
her.
Little did I know that I was going to lose
my mother that very same year.
So, that was one of the worst emotional journeys
I have felt in my life because this was a
tribute to her, and I wanted her to see it
while she was alive.
Sadly, she couldn't because she passed away
in September.
I kind of started doing the background work
sometime in May, June, and she couldn't be
part of that.
But I know every day she's up above, looking
and really loving this journey that I've created
for myself and for others.
And it's been such a gratifying experience
because if not for her, this wouldn't have
happened.
[Music]
During COVID, there were a few adult students
who wanted to pursue this, and we went online.
Our curriculum ran online on Zoom for two
years.
It was twice a week, two hours training.
You're sweating, and that really changes the
chemical balance in the body and creates a
lot of endorphins to be generated.
As a health professional, scientifically,
it is proven if you learn a new art form or
any new thing in your life, your cognition
will improve.
Cases were receding, and my mental position
at that time was I was very tired, very lethargic,
not able to focus.
In some sense, I had lost some purpose of
life just because of the whole COVID environment.
Doing what's required in a dance class, I
was slowly able to transform myself.
When we got our freedom back, they were back
in the studio.
I'm traveling from NSW every week, even though
it is very challenging for me to travel from
there to here.
I, however, make these big sessions almost
every week.
It's really fun.
It calms me and helps me with fitness and
stamina.
I feel proud of myself because I've been dancing
for a long time, and I've gone this far.
So today, I feel so much, I look forward to
these classes.
However bad a day I would have had during
the week, every Friday, there's this feeling
of ecstasy that I have a class on Saturday,
and I want to come here and learn something
new and be a better version of myself.
I think that thought process really helps
me in staying fit mentally and having a very
positive outlook towards life.
As students, both young and experienced, you
know, two plus two is four, three plus two
is five, and, you know, simple math.
But one gets to apply that in dance.
So we teach that in a sense as to how to render
that beat.
[Music]
Surrendering the beat has a few elements.
There is footwork that's primarily going to
instigate the beat because you're going to
strike the foot on the floor to initiate the
beat.
But in order to understand that footwork,
you need to understand what is the structure
of the beat in the mind.
And thirdly, you need to synchronize that
beat structure head to toe and be able to
move in formation and be able to express through
your face.
All of this won't come into play if you're
not able to work through that art of counting
in your mind.
And that actually enables your math concept
at another level.
The way
[Music]
This one's actually an inspiration.
When we had COVID in the middle of COVID,
and I have another kind of art that I pursue
as part of my training, which is bridging.
That's something I got introduced to back
in the States.
I know people say it's fusion, and we stay
away from the word because everything is fusion
these days.
Bridging is very particular because it has
an 80-20 or 70-30 percentage where the prerequisite
for that is Bharatnatyam, and it gets embellished
with different costumes, not necessarily the
Bharatnatyam traditional one.
The music is very different.
I think about bridging as a transition into
contemporary.
If you know an art, you could actually, and
if you know the rhythm and the beats, you
could pretty much dance to any tune.
I took the lyrics of the song and I just translated
that into the Nritya component of Bharatnatyam,
which means facial expressions.
Through that, we've done a lot more collaborations.
We've done Bharatnatyam and Hip-Hop.
We've done a recent commission with...
This was very interesting.
We did it with the Maloya artist.
Maloya artist, Maloya is from The Reunion
Island.
That's a dance form that comes out of Reunion
Island, which has a beautiful infusion of
African, Chinese, Indian, and French cultures.
It was absolutely mesmerizing to bring in
the Tamil culture and the African culture
and the French culture.
We did a commission for 60 minutes, which
was beautiful.
When people start to relate to other cultures,
they have better relationships because the
younger generation needs to understand they're
going to be in a group of people from multiple
ethnicities.
They need to understand how to relate to each
other, how to get along.
Exposing them at an early age is only going
to spark all of those beautiful conversations.
There are a couple of students, or a few students,
at a very young age living in a country which
doesn't majority represent themselves.
The feeling of acceptance is very difficult
for a young person, especially in a school
environment.
Learning this dance has helped them really
reduce the anxiety and feel more confident
about themselves.
Yeah, I like expressing myself through dance
and through different hand gestures.
Like this means very scared or surprised.
I would do this.
That's how I express my anger with my friends.
I show it.
My expressions are more lively and more happy.
But sometimes I get a little bit mad, so I
can also show it through that.
And then, yeah, without saying anything.
Did you understand?
Yes, they get the message.
[Laughter]
...alright...
[Music]
It's character-building.
It teaches you a lot more because all of
those art forms tap into a deeper sense of
yourself, and they really help you during
adverse times.
When you're at the bottommost part of your
life, art will help revive you.
You have something to step on and then climb
up.
For me, dancing is all about connection.
Connection to three different things: connection
to the earth on which we strike and move on,
connection to my culture, from which I've
learned many lessons, and connection to my
body and myself.
I think also connection to my body is a very
important aspect of dancing.
I never would have thought this before I started
dancing.
Dancing has made me more in tune with myself
and made me learn more about myself.
I don't see Chandralaya confined to the South
Asian diaspora.
It has to expand beyond that because we are
in a very cultural environment, and collaboration
is the key for the next how many ever years.
So, the more cultural communities collaborate,
creating powerful art, and I see Chandralaya
playing a front and center role in there,
collaborating with art organizations to create
meaningful conversations about social, economic
issues through art.
That is success to me.
I feel that that sense of purpose is just
heightening every time the conversations,
the relationships.
I would, any day, cherish all of that.
You have to believe in what you're saying
and you have to execute the same, and there
are no shortcuts.
You're coming in to learn something that is
very deep-rooted in culture.
It's not just about dance.
It's about your entire physical and mental well-being.
[Music]